Okay.
It's time for really obvious stuff that in
the Trump era we actually have to say out
loud because a lot of people don't seem to
understand it or do they fallen for talking
points and have been confused about what the
reality is.
The foreign help that Trump said last week
in an interview with George Stephanopoulos,
he would welcome from other countries is illegal.
Okay.
Last week to remind you, Donald Trump was
interviewed on ABC news by George Stephanopoulos
and he was asked, what would you do president
Trump in 2020, once again, Russia or China
or whoever comes to you with dirt on your
eventual democratic opponent.
Uh, and Donald Trump said that he would accept
the information because of course nothing
says I didn't collude in 2016 like saying
I'd be willing to collude in 2020.
Let me remind you of what Donald Trump said,
just so we all are, uh, familiar with the
clip I'm referring to
today.
We are going to the FBI when he got that.
Let's put yourself in a position.
You're a congressman.
Somebody comes up and says, Hey, I have information
on your opponent.
Do you call the FBI?
I don't think from day one.
I've seen a lot of things over my life.
I don't think in my whole life I've ever called
the FBI and my whole life, I don't, you don't
call the FBI, you throw somebody out in your
office, you do whatever you want to go or
got a stolen briefing book.
He called the FBI.
Well, that's different is stolen briefing,
but this isn't a story.
This is somebody that said, we have information
on your opponent.
Oh, let me call the FPA.
Give me a break.
Life doesn't work.
That or director says, and that's what should
happen.
The FBI director is wrong.
Your campaign this time around, if foreigners,
if Russia, if China, if someone else offers
the information on the opponent, should they
accept it or should they call the FBI?
I think maybe you do both.
I think you might want to listen, I don't
this nothing wrong with listening.
If somebody called from a country, Norway,
we have information on your opponent.
Oh, I think I'd want to hear it.
You want that kind of interference in our
elections.
It's not an interference.
They have information.
I think I'd take it if I thought there was
something wrong, I'd go maybe to the FBI if
I thought there was something wrong, but when
somebody comes up with upper research, right,
they come up with up or research, oh, let's
call the FBI.
The FBI doesn't have enough agents to take
care of it, but you go and talk honestly to
congressmen, they all do it.
They always have, and that's the way it is.
It's called oppo research.
Okay.
So all of that foreign oppo research that
Trump is referring to is illegal to accept.
As an American presidential candidate.
There was a very good piece in the La Times
which outlines a variety of different views
on this and what's important to understand
is that it is quote unlawful for a foreign
national, directly or indirectly keywords
directly or indirectly to make a contribution
or donation of money or other thing of value
or other thing of value important or to make
an express or implied promise to make a contribution
or donation in connection with a federal,
state or local election.
It is also illegal for a campaign to quote,
solicit, accept, or receive anything of value
from a foreigner.
So it's two sided.
It's illegal for the foreigners to do it.
Whether you can actually hold them accountable
if they're not in the United States is a question
mark.
It seems to be no, and it's equally illegal
for the recipient in the United States to
do the receiving.
Trump said he would accept it and receive
it.
It is therefore something that would be against
the law.
Uh, Ellen Weintraub chairs the FEC.
She put out a statement saying, quote, let
me make something 100% clear to the American
public and anyone running for public office.
It is illegal for any person to solicit, accept,
or receive anything of value from a foreign
national in connection with the US election.
Now, let's be thorough.
There are some lawyers who are disputing that
dirt on opponents is a specifically quantifiable
thing of value, meaning it might not be illegal
in this way.
The idea is dirt on an opponent which helps
you win is worth what if you can't put a specific
dollar value on it, it's not quantifiably
a thing of value and therefore it might sort
of skirt around the illegality that Ellen
Weintraub says exists.
So you might say, well, if I get dirt from
my opponent and it helps me win and my salary
is $175,000 a year, was the dirt worth 175,000?
Well, it's not quite so cut and dry.
But what this ignores is that it's worth something.
And this is why lots of legal experts say,
even if we can't say exactly what the value
is of that dirt on opponents, it has value.
Uh, and in addition to that, the foreign country
has presumably spent some amount of money
and resources in gathering that dirt on your
opponents, which gives it more specific value.
If it costs a foreign national $50,000 to
gather this dirt on your opponent, then we
can much more easily say, well, it's worth
$50,000 because that's what it costs the foreign
national.
That's what it costs a foreign national to
obtain that information.
So I think it is one of the weakest defenses.
I've heard that it's not really illegal because
we can't specifically quantify the value of
the dirt.
It has value.
It costs money to obtain the dirt.
And by the way, Donald Trump also said in
that interview with George Stephanopoulos
that everyone is doing this.
That's not true.
I mean, sure, it's probably true that someone
is doing it.
But unless Donald Trump can start citing specific
examples of where American candidates and
elected officials excepted things of value
in this way from foreign powers, it's on him
to tell us that everybody is doing it and
to prove that everybody is doing it.
And think how far we've come from the beginning
to this interview with George Stephanopoulos.
There was nothing with any foreign country.
There was something, but no, Trump insiders
had a clue.
There was some thing and some Trump insiders
how to clue, but it wasn't illegal to, Oh
yeah, we do it all again in 2020, uh, emboldened
like the sort of little kids that they effectively
are.
Don't let them get away with this.
Don't let them get away with this again in
2020 we can vote them out.
Yes, the playing field is not level it stacked
against us.
As I said in the first segment in today's
show, uh, but if enough people vote, we can
override that and we can actually get them
out and that's what we need to be doing because
he's saying it on national.
Yeah,
television.
He would do it all again.
Let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at d pacman.
The show is on Twitter at David Pakman show,